maybe you'll even make some friends
they're still creepy and pretty kooky
[Music]
it's a magical place where i met your
mother
yes the adams family is back for a new
netflix series and catherine zeta jones
is slipping into morticia's signature
all-black attire
by god you're right
in our first look at the show centered
around adam's family daughter wednesday
katherine serves gothic glam sporting
morticia's signature sleek jet black
hair and an all black fitted gown the 52
year old actress looks like she was made
for the role and louise guzman's gomez
is just as on point
this adams family reimagining is the
brainchild of tim burton the filmmaker
known for blending comedy and creepy i'm
so excited to be working with you know
the great tim burton and
and you know actually the makeup and and
costume designer who i've worked with
before
full of mystery
mayhem
and murder
i think i'm going to love it here
judging from the trailer fans are in for
a spooky good time the whole family can
enjoy
[Music]
it's definitely like the not cheesy but
you know the slapstick humor yeah it's
it's adam's family jenna ortega plays
catherine's on-screen daughter the show
is all about wednesday's high school
experience
i
feel very lucky to have been able to
portray wednesday adams as a teenager
and to watch her go off into boarding
school and kind of insert herself in a
place full of outcasts
hey freak
this is a closed practice
the only person who gets to torture my
brother is me
[Music]
i think it's been really interesting
doing an eight episode series and just
kind of creating a deeper emotional arc
for her and giving her a bit more range
the thing about wednesday's we've never
seen her on screen for such a long
period of time she's always been the one
line you know joke and jenna told us it
was an honor to play the iconic role
following in the footsteps of christina
ritchie
don't be a baby
i know what i'm doing
christina starred in two big screen
adaptations of the comic series and
plays a new character in this iteration
i got to work with her and and i learned
a lot from her i mean
in my personal opinion wednesday will
never get any better like there's no so
that's the thing about like my portrayal
too it's like okay well i'll do what i
can and just do whatever i can to you
know make sure i'm not ripping anybody
else off or doing anything but i have
immense respect for her and i think she
will always be wednesday in my eyes fair
enough but from what we've seen
catherine and jenna are nailing their
portrayals of our favorite frightening
family
[Music]
you